so today we're going to talk about the
good the bad and the ugly related to
peanuts and peanut butter so what would
you like to know about first the good or
the bad or the ugly the ugly okay let's
start there well first thing you need to
know is that a peanut is not an actual
nut it's not a tree nut it's a legume
that actually grows in the soil okay so
let's start off with the shell the shell
of the nut is actually soft and it can
easily absorb things in the soil like
chemicals because the peanut is one of
the most heavily sprayed crops out there
I'm talking about pesticides
insecticides herbicides fungicides that
actually get into the soil and that nut
just pulls it right in now peanuts
generally are not GMO okay genetically
modified however the peanut crop is
rotated with the cotton crop which is
GMO so guess what you're getting the
glyphosate which is the main chemical
roundup-ready that actually is used in
spraying the weeds you're getting it in
the soil so it's going right into the
peanuts and when you look at when
glyphosate which is the herbicide
Roundup Ready was introduced in the
environment you'll see a dica Winson
ants spike and peanut allergies I just
wonder if there's a connection between
the allergies that people are getting
and the chemicals in the food what do
you think put it put your comment down
below I want to know what you think
about that but there was a spike a 400%
more allergies when glyphosate was
introduced also peanut butter batches
were tested I'll put the link down below
and they showed traces of glyphosate so
that's the ugly all right now let's go
to the bat there's something called a
flow toxin this is a toxin produced by a
fungus that grows on peanuts and corn
and soybean and other grains so peanuts
have much higher levels of a toxin
called aflatoxin which causes liver
cancer also many brands of peanut butter
when you buy them are loaded with extra
sugar chemicals hydrogenated oils
so definitely always read the label and
make sure it doesn't have anything else
in it except peanuts and maybe some sea
salt all right that's the bad news
all right let's switch to the good news
all right there's a type of peanut
butter out there called Valencia which
has the lowest amounts of aflatoxins
okay that's good right
also when you buy organic peanut butter
you're getting less chemicals like
pesticides insecticides herbicides and
fungicides so if we combine the organic
with Valencia peanut butter you're
getting less chemicals especially the
glyphosate and you're getting less toxin
from the mold that's the good news all
right more good news when you roast the
nut or you germinate the nut which is
soaking the nut overnight to release the
anti nutrients and other factors that
might create irritation with your
digestive system you increase the
availability of the nutrients so you can
actually increase certain nutrients that
were bound up because of some of these
anti nutrient compounds all right here's
some more good news there's a substance
called chlorophyll this is the green
stuff in the plant there's very similar
chemistry to our own blood but it uses
magnesium instead of iron but
chlorophyll has the capacity to lower
this toxin which comes from the fungus
okay aflatoxin and so if you consume
some salad or something green or
wheatgrass juice powder after you eat
the peanut butter jelly sandwich which
I'm just kidding right now you wouldn't
want to do that
but if you're just doing nuts or peanut
butter with something that has
chlorophyll you reduce this toxin so
that's good the last good news is that
peanuts in general are comparable and
nutrition to other nuts so they do have
vitamin E they have the B vitamins they
have phytonutrients and they also have
protein hey guys and you know what I'm
really sorry that eating has to be this
complex sometimes but I just wanted to
bring your awareness up of some of the
barriers that you're running up against
with the chemicals introduced into our
food supply and also some of the fungus
and the toxic effect
certain things alright thanks for
watching hey guys I'm not sure if you
have my app yet dr. Berg app it's
totally free you should download it ok
this is what it looks like you click it
it gives you all sorts of great
resources I have all my YouTube videos
on this out ok and it's regularly
uploading the most recent ones all the
YouTube videos are also converted to
audio versions ok so you can use it when
you're walking exercising driving your
car I have a mini chorus on there I'll
be putting additional courses I have a
lot of recipes on there this is new and
also a PDF resources so there's various
downloads PDFs that you can get as well
and if you wouldn't mind after you
download it check it out give me your
unbiased review and tell me how you like
it I want to know